welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and the Guardians of the Galaxy vol
3 trailer introduces the high
evolutionary Herbert Windham Marvel's
Ultimate geneticist and a villain deeply
intertwined with Rocket's long
mysterious origin story but the visuals
and production design revealed in this
trailer are so bizarre and trippy the
high evolutionary is now looking less
like an employee at 23andMe who took his
work home with him and more like a
madman who constructs entire worlds and
pocket realities to actualize his
eugenic cruelty meaning this guy is on a
power scale much higher than we thought
and will play a much bigger role to MCU
World building going forward than we
realize so let's break down everything
we know about the high evolutionary his
role in Guardians volume 3 is connection
to Adam Warlock and Rocket's origin his
importance to the Marvel Comics and his
ultimate plan to bring about the next
big era in the MCU the high evolutionary
Herbert Wyndham is Marvel's top
geneticist and Associate of X-Men
villain Nathaniel Essex Mr Sinister
Windham burst appeared in the Mighty
Thor issue 134 1966 as the leader of the
animal human hybrids called the new men
his Knights of wundergore the next issue
135 explored its backstory as a gen
index researcher trying to experiment
with Evolution play God all that good
stuff and he said he discovered a trove
of uranium that made him Super Rich
allowing him to realize his vision and
he established a base on Mount
wundergore now since then High
evolutionary has been linked with
several Marvel figures it was his serum
that created Spider-Woman Jessica Drew
one of his new men was Boba who nursed
Pietro and Wanda maximoff as babies on
Mount woodigore and he's the one who
gave adam the name warlock after Adam
left his creators in The Enclave he's
also known for creating an alternate
pure earth called counter Earth in a
microsecond out of dimensional sink to
hide it from the main Earth so a
combination of these things appears to
be playing out in Guardians volume 3. it
looks like the high evolutionary will be
tied to Adam Warlock perhaps leading
those white clad researchers whom I
believe to be the enclave and it looks
like Windham created this whole race of
new men these animalistic humanoids who
live in a 1980s version of counter Earth
which in the MCU may just be called half
world since the 2014 film listed as
Rocket and Lila's origin world and yes I
think rocket and Lyla are among these
hybrid creations of Herbert Wyndham
James Gunna said the volume three is
gonna be closing out the story that he
has been telling since the beginning and
in that 2014 film the camera lingered on
Rocket cybernetic implant scars and
later rocket raged at Peter and Drax
about his past well I didn't ask to get
made I didn't ask to be torn apart and
put back together over and over and turn
into some
some little monster this backstory was
further explored in volume 2 as an
intense moment between rocket and yondu
you can fool yourself and everyone else
careful me I know who you are you don't
know anything about me loser I know
everything about you I know you play
like you're the meanest and the hardest
but actually you're the most scared of
all shut up I know them scientists what
made you never gave a rat's ass about
you I'm serious them scientists what
made you it's nonsense grammar there but
Michael Rooker just has a way of making
any mush-mouth and make perfect sense so
I think the scientists that yondu
referred to there were Herbert Wyndham
and his Cult of genetic researchers we
only see glimpses of in this trailer
that would not surprise me if they are
revealed in this movie to be The Enclave
the same group who created Adam Warlock
the ones who supplied Aisha with his
cocoon in the Guardians Volume 2
post-credits scene it is officially the
holiday season that means stressing out
about what presents to buy stressing out
about [ __ ] travel stressing out about
pumpkin spice sneaking into Foods where
it doesn't belong oh God all the stress
is enough to make your hair fall out
unless your God keeps keeps offers
clinically proven research-backed
treatments to stop hair loss and improve
hair growth two out of three guys will
experience hair loss by the time they're
35 but with keeps you can get quality
expert care without ever visiting the
doctor's office or a pharmacy all keeps
treatment plans are recommended by a
licensed medical provider and delivered
straight to your door at about half the
cost of a traditional Pharmacy each
treatment plan comes with a full year of
unlimited messaging so you can connect
with your medical provider about
anything anytime keeps has a network of
Expert Medical advisors prescribers and
Care Specialists to support you in
making your hair goals a reality whether
you're looking to prevent hair loss
stimulate hair growth or just take
better care of the hair that you have
keeps has you covered hair loss stops
with keeps to get 50 off your first
order go to keeps.com new rockstars or
click the link in the description that's
k-e-e-p-s.com new rockstars now at San
Diego Comic-Con last summer chickwini
Ouija gave a monologue in character as a
high evolutionary that sounded like a
declaration of the villain's core
philosophy and his mission as i gaze out
and this crowd I'm reminded of my sole
purpose in the universe to take
unevolved disgusting
low life scum such as yourself and
enhance you genetically
to something
less reprehensible thank you for
inspiring me with how vomitus you all
are the bile in the back of my throat as
I look at you is all the motivation I
need to move forward and create the
perfect species
dissect all of you and see what I can
learn create the perfect species and
just act all of you and see what I can
learn yeah it sounds like Herbert
Windham was behind both the creation of
Adam Warlock the perfect species and the
dissection of life forms like rocket his
experiments on rocket and Lila and the
other new men of counter Earth or half
World whatever it's called were the
early steps of a process that would
eventually arrive at a genetically
perfect specimen of Adam so how does
this connect to Peter Quill in mantis in
volume three well the holiday special
confirmed that mantis is also a child of
ego ego is a Celestial making her Peter
Quill's half-sister and both of them
descendants of celestial DNA gun has
indicated that that's going to be an
important plot point in volume three
Peter's Celestial ancestry was something
of a Fascination to Aisha a sovereign
obsessed with genetic Purity what is
your heritage Mr quill my mother is from
Earth and your father aim for Missouri
that's all I know I see it within you an
unorthodox genealogy a hybrid that seems
particularly Reckless they told me you
people were conceited douchebags but
that isn't true at all
oh [ __ ] I'm using my wrong eye again
aren't I and now when we look back at
this it's clear that rocket was
especially insulted by Aisha's genetic
superiority because it reminded him of
his Tormentor and windham's Obsession to
create the perfect species using rocket
like a lab rat now I am speculating here
but that fleshy spiral structure we see
in the trailer if it is indeed hijack's
spinal tissue of a Celestial like the
corpse tissue of nowhere the high
evolutionary's ultimate plot maybe to
use Celestial light to commit a form of
mass genocide on any creature that
doesn't have a hereditary connection to
the celestials quill and mantis would be
spared along with Adam Warlock other
eternals and Titans and gods and other
evolved life forms like maybe Herbert
wind himself but all the rest of us
lower life forms nope sorry my mind just
goes to this place because you know
ethnic genocide seems to be the final
solution of any villain to obsessed with
genetics but beyond this film there are
also two major implications for what
Herbert Wyndham brings to the MCU first
is association with mount unigor in the
maximos mount munigor was just
introduced as an MCU location and Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of man where
one is darkhold Temple was located and
in the comics this mountain is also
where Herbert window lives and in his
castle one of his new men Bova nurses
and Vince Wanda and Pietro Bova was
teased as an Easter egg in the animated
intro of One Division episode 2. in that
run of the comics featured Windham
claiming he was the one who advanced
Wanda and Pietro and then later passed
them off as common mutants so that plus
windham's association with X-Men Bill
and Mr Sinister suggest to me that
Windham is the obvious character to
finally give the MCU an explanation of
the mutant Gene the genetic
predisposition shared by people like not
more Kamala Khan and others with
nebulous power sets and currently more
questions than answers as to why
exposure to things like Cosmic radiation
affected them differently than it
affects most other people if you think
about it the villain Kang is the Marvel
Mastermind who unlocked the secrets of
timelines in the Multiverse the high
evolutionary is a mastermind who
unlocked the secrets of celestial
genealogy and mutations violations to
the sacred timeline gave us the
Multiverse violations to the celestials
plan gives us mutants Jane's gun with
the 2014 Guardians of the Galaxy
contributed to the MCU the universe
building plot points of Thanos in the
history of the Infinity Stones those did
not really exist in the MCU until James
Gunn got here and they later proved to
be essential to Avengers Infinity war
and Avengers end game we always think
Marvel directors are going to establish
these big plot points in the MCU but
when the credits roll we realize oh
they're just trying to tell the story
that they wanted to tell and weren't
really interested in establishing big
rules for this universe but the
exception of that has been James Gunn
that's why Warner Brothers picked him to
build their DC Universe so with
guardians volume 3 being James Gunn's
final Marvel Cinematic Universe film
what better way to say goodbye to the
MCU then leave it with a Parting Gift of
finally some clarity of how exactly
mutants exist in this universe you can
follow me on Tick Tock Hive Instagram
and Twitter at avos follow new rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]